Now, let's get into the poll.
Cuz you asked me to do this.
Okay? Let's play the video, right? Can
we play it? Will I get flagged cuz it's
on YouTube?
>> [music]
>> I shouldn't get flagged. All right, now
we get into the meat I got to send to my
>> [clears throat]
>> my couch. Please, Father. Please, Holy
Holy Spirit.
Heal me of allergies, any disease, in
Jesus' name. Pope visits grand mufti of
Algiers calls for mutual respect and
peace. Well, now we're going to go into
it. Now, we're going to bring out the
implication. Now,
we're going to discuss
why [clears throat] it's easy to be an
armchair quarterback.
If you take a moment to reflect and you
think deeply,
>> [clears throat]
>> you will not envy
being a bishop, especially of the most
recognizable church on the planet.
Whether you guys like it or not,
the one
bishop
who is seen by the outside world as the
leader of the Christians is the Pope.
This is just a fact. I'm not saying it's
true
that he is the leader. The world
the world
that
are not Christian,
they don't know about the differences,
the infighting.
What they see is that the Pope
is the leader of Christianity.
The
weight,
the burden
of the church is on his shoulders.
Muslims, Hindus, Buddhists, government
agencies
see the Pope not [clears throat] just as
the leader of one particular branch.
>> [clears throat]
>> They see him
as
the visible leader for the church
universally.
Right or wrong, that's a fact. Now, why
is that
scary?
Why is that
dangerous? You'll see. Okay.
Another aspect, when filmmakers
when
cartoonists
who want to make fun
of Christianity, you'll see their number
one target is the Catholic Church.
From caricatures [clears throat]
of the Pope,
caricatures of bishops,
and outright mockery blasphemy of the
Eucharist. Even when they make a satanic
mass, black mass,
what do Luciferian Satanists do? They go
and look for a Catholic Church to steal
a Catholic host. Why is that?
So, keep that in mind as I'm about to go
and deep dive. I'm going to give you
some more biblical receipts.
>> [music]
>> The whole
eyes [clears throat] of the world
are on him. You notice that?
The whole world is on him.
All the cameras all over the world, the
Muslim countries
are seeing what he will do. Keep this in
mind.
>> [music]
>> Now, for those people who say, "See, he
bowed to Allah."
>> [clears throat]
[sighs]
>> Okay. But anyway,
keep in mind they say, "See, he's
bowing, isn't he?" Well, we'll get
there.
>> [music]
[singing]
[music]
>> Why would you drown out his speech with
music? I have no idea.
Genius, but I'll come back to this. I
just want you to watch this.
>> [music]
>> Okay.
You [clears throat] saw him, right? Like
Michael Lawler, he was bowing.
He didn't say anything externally.
>> [singing]
>> You think he's dumb?
You think
the Pope doesn't know his Bible?
You think he's dumb?
You think he doesn't know the Bible or
at least theologians who know the Bible,
who know Second Kings?
You think that when he bowed his head,
you don't think he's glorifying,
invoking Jesus
to save this place in the Muslims? How
do you know that?
How do you know what is in his heart, D?
How do you know what he's doing here?
And if you're telling me he's wrong,
then Elisha's wrong for telling Naaman,
"You can bow in the temple of a false
god so long as in your heart you're
worshipping Yahweh."
Why do you guys sit in judgment of this
man when you guys are biblically
uneducated, illiterate?
Why is that?
I'm just giving you Bible, guys. Do Do
you think you know Bible? Like here, D
says, "Me and my Bible."
Do you know your Bible that well?
Walking with Christ, I hope you're not
saying you think he's wrong after I just
gave you scripture cuz I'm going to send
you to Mike Winger.
You're with me there, Walking with
Christ? You got one letter.
So, D, tell me. How do you know he's not
following the rule laid down by Elisha
that he's now entering the house of
Satan and praying to the true God
to save the people of that household?
So, why were you scandalized, D?
Why did you send me this clip? Let me
show you.
So, what she sent me.
Iranian Christian here.
So, today a bunch of figures from the
Islamic regime came to support Pope Leo
from Donald Trump, which is very ironic
to me, and I will explain in a second
why. The sole issue started when Trump
called Pope Leo out for being soft on
crime and tolerant of the Islamic regime
having nuclear weapons. So, why the
irony? Because the Islamic regime has a
long history of prosecuting religious
minorities, largest one being the
Christians, especially the Christian
converts
like myself. He just told you Islamic
regime
persecutes
>> [clears throat]
>> Christians, especially converts.
And imprisons them. Now, what do you
think the Muslims are going to do to the
Christians if what they view as the
leader of the church says, "Allah is a
devil, Muslims are sons of the devil,
the mosque is a place of Satan."
What then will they do to the Christians
in Muslim lands when their leader says
this? Genius, explain it to me.
Let's see how smart you guys are.
What do you think will happen if he
speaks out loud
and tells you all of the Quran is Satan,
the Quran is a book of Satan,
Muslims are sons of Satan?
What then will they do to Christians
in Muslim countries because of him?
Geniuses, Einsteins,
that you're quick to condemn without
understanding
the repercussions,
ramifications
of him speaking as freely as someone
like me
in my house, on my couch, on the
internet.
Explain it to me. And I'm going to give
you an example. Yeah, I was going to go
to Pope Benedict. It happened recently
when 2006
Pope Benedict quoted a medieval
theologian saying Muhammad brought
nothing new, he only brought evil, and
the Christians got persecuted and killed
because of those statements by Pope
Benedict.
Here you go.
Right here.
Put in Christians attacked after Pope
Benedict's speech.
Following Pope Benedict XVI's September
2006 Regensburg address,
which quoted a 14th century text
criticizing Islam,
widespread protests and attacks on
Christians occurred, particularly in the
Middle East and Somalia. Churches were
firebombed,
D,
in the West Bank and Gaza,
and an Italian nun was killed in
Somalia, you geniuses.
And you condemned the Pope for what he
did.
You guys will answer to God
for being so quick to condemn and judge
a man
who knows the eyes of the world are upon
him and what he says can result in
Christians being murdered because of him
as he lives in the comfort of the
Vatican. He shows more love for his
neighbor than you because he can live
peacefully in the Vatican, but who's
going to be persecuted, beaten
and imprisoned?
>> [clears throat]
>> The Christians on the ground.
But you're very quick to condemn because
you're not in that position.
We know it's not the Pope's fault. We're
saying that the Pope realized
even if I say something, others will be
condemned and blamed because of my
words.
You understand?
So,
the man is showing the heart of a
shepherd.
He understands the Muslim mindset. He
remembers what happened to Pope Benedict
cuz he was there when Pope Benedict made
those statements and he saw what they
did to Christians. Your sister, an
Italian nun, got
got killed in Somalia because of what
the Pope said.
And you armchair quarterback,
you sad excuses of Christians, sit on
your fat
on the couch and condemn him
living in comfort.
See why I say
I'm not trying to popsplain. Understand
his position, right or wrong.
And I don't envy his position. That's
why I go silent because
I wonder
would I have done a better job?
if I was Pope, how would I speak? Cuz
now I know I can get my fellow Assyrian
Chaldeans
in Iraq. Why? Cuz number one, they'll
see me as a Christian and the head of
the church. Number two, they'll say,
"Oh, he's Assyrian Chaldean. Let's now
the Assyrian Chaldean women in Iraq.
Let's now
the Assyrian Chaldean to now hit them
where it hurts.
You want me there?
I'm trying to see it from his eyes. He's
got the weight of Christians on his
shoulder. Whether it's right or wrong,
here.
Iraq priest
for Pope's speech D. Do you want the
blood of that priest on your hand? Al
Jazeera, Iraq priest for Pope's speech.
The relatives of a Christian priest was
kidnapped.
See why I get angry now, son of his
right hand?
When people sit in judgment?